[Music]
where Daniels takes the stage and he
owns it you know what I mean like he
goes up he's like everybody shut up
Threepio deserves his moment well yeah
do you know that something struck me the
Threepio has been put down now you know
in all of the Star Wars movies they have
him around because he says he's very
clever and he's it's kind of useful in
some ways love him and treat him badly
so today it suddenly struck me yes the
droid fights back
how many lives do you think Threepio has
saved it would be beyond his program to
to boast about it bugs am I'm not sure
that many actually because a lot of
humans have their own common sense in
the end not to go there but he is a
really parental figure and he just cares
and you know caring is not a bad thing
in this world that stage was so
emotional I cried several times I don't
know about you well four mean the whole
thing is emotional because this this
episode to end does wrap up the whole
Star Wars saga and there will be other
Star Wars movies but the last time
playing Threepio II think I in films yes
I believe so and therefore the last day
on the set for me was like I was really
hanging on in there I pretty much lost
it
3p I was much more stiff lip than me
[Music]